thank you
oh Vindication for me
clone troopers
oh my God oh my God oh my God this is
like Vegas this is like me at 3am in
Vegas
just lost confused scared I need an
adult
where's all my money
[Laughter]
bed
he it's actually Cannon his his the guy
is Canon yeah
uh canaran
I think you might be right terrible
nickname but great character man this is
just prequel Redemption again like just
giving this guy who has taken so much
crap and giving him the greatest role in
the Mandalorian this is incredible
welcome back to new rock stars the
Mandalorian chapter 20 did it everybody
they did it they introduced an old
friend as a new character dank ferric
what a time to be alive we now know who
saved grogu we now know what we have
several different definitions of a
foundling and I'm at best man that man
can keep a secret because you know he
was really itching to tell everybody
yeah this shows his future this is the
break room presents Wookie leaks our
weekly Mandalorian after show I'm Eric
Boss my Easter egg breakdown is coming
tomorrow right now I'm here discussing
this episode with Tommy bechtold and
just like a tiny crap disguises a rock
we have a surprise guest joining us this
week Hector Navarro it's me I'm a tiny
crap yes oh my God what uh what an
exciting exciting week you know I every
every week they sneak in these little
supplies at any point grogu can
flashbacks who is oh God that was so
stressful too there's nothing about the
repetitive like that press thing that
was slamming down that was giving me so
much anxiety I'm like is she gonna try
and push grogu under this thing like I
don't know why it's the same thing when
I watched the hydraulic press squishing
Skittles yeah I'm like oh my god when
mice when Ahmed best saved me from a
horrible day at school
uh let's recap Tommy Talk us through
what happened this episode absolutely uh
well for an episode that really only had
three locations A lot happened I gotta
say so much I'm gonna try not to be
overly emotional let's go we open on a
well-regulated Mando militia in the
morning as everybody's kind of just
showing off their new shiny toys open
carrying Dan decides he's gonna go full
hockey dad and he puts grogu up against
Ragnar we learned Vizsla uh looks like
uh Paz vislo was raw dog in at some
point about 11 years ago
then little Wesley little Ragnar was
stolen by a raptor also confusing that
these things names are raptors right
like that's kind of right
Tommy Tommy Raptor just means bird of
prey remember that's what Sam Neal said
in Jurassic Park one right that's true
bird of prey so this is literally sounds
like a six foot turkey
uh can they get a new training ground
yeah we're just on this beach front some
people shouldn't be Beach people some
people there's no need we know we know
that the armor and pause Vizsla and
everybody were living on Navarro before
right like season one of Mando but then
like they got exposed so did they have
to go but like after that after that
happened did they all look to each other
and go we have to go back to that super
dangerous planet we have nowhere else to
go that's dumb move somewhere else I
think the armor is like the mayor of
Amity island in the Jaws it's just like
I will not close to the beaches we gotta
keep these beaches open mandalorians
stand back and stand by all right so
Ragnar stolen by a raptor which Hector
has so brilliantly informed us just
means bird of prey shouts shouts and
murmurs to Sam Neal uh bocatan's like I
got this I'm gonna go get this boy back
it's no big deal you know one thing I do
want to point out I love the way the
episode this episode dealt with the jet
packs being faulty I feel like normally
jet packs in all movies and TV work
perfectly every time and these guys ran
out of gas trying to chase down uh young
Ragnar then we get this great scene with
the armorer alone with grogu as she kind
of teaches them about Mandalorian
customs and that leads us to the moment
in the show we flash back to that night
of Order 66 the Jedis are fighting off
clone troopers of course a brilliant
young boy months ago named Thomas
Bechtel predicted that they would be
clone troopers carving through that door
go back and watch my video the receipts
are there I may have speculated other
people too I might have said Darth Vader
or something's really stupid and then
people in the comments roasted me so
grogu gets in the elevator who's there
to rescue him Ahmed best baby kelleran
Beck is there I gotta say
I I you know all all kidding aside
the the fact that Ahmed best got this
incredible role in this show a he
deserves it and B it's such a Redemptive
thing because the reality is you can
make fun of Jar Jar Binks all you want
I'm at best as a good actor I mean he
wouldn't have booked the role of Jar Jar
Binks if he wasn't a good actor they
don't hire people for a Star Wars movie
if they suck at acting so now we get to
see beautiful Ahmed best face we gaze
upon him with our own eyes uh we take we
remove our helmets and slowly suffocate
like uh Darth Vader and uh return the
Jedi okay focus Thomas uh the rescue
team tracks down Ragnar and they they
rescue him although he tries to mess it
up and we see those three little baby
birds
I thought they were gonna get little
bits of Ragnar then we find out that he
is pause vizsla's son he's my son Paz is
like sorry bro mandalorians don't wrap
it up Bo returns with damaged armor and
she replaces one of her sigils with a
mythosaur and then reveals to the
armorer
that she may have seen a mythosaur and
the armor is like yeah that's fine I'm
never gonna give you a straight answer
the armor is like my one friend Nick who
has never given me a straight answer to
a question in his life and it's so
frustrating I honestly don't we've been
friends for 25 years I don't think we've
ever had a real conversation anyway
uh
so yeah that was the episode boys were
you in tears I was in tears I shed a
thug tear for that one I clapped loudly
I cheered I I had such a great response
to the moment because I feel like I when
we heard the name get him to kelleran I
was racking the Rolodex of Star Wars
characters in my brain going Keller and
should I know that name is this like a
character that we've known before that
we've met before is this from the
expanded universe is this like from a
comic book or a novel or have we not
seen this character in live action but
I'm like that sounds so familiar Keller
and what is that Keller is that from
Rebels what is this and as soon as that
door slid open
I felt like it's Ahmed best I've
actually seen every episode of Jedi
Temple challenge yes where he played
Keller and back and for a long time from
since that show came out and I think
that they produced that show that great
kids game show that was like Legends of
the Hidden Temple and it was so cute and
so well done I think they produced that
show before the pandemic changed things
and I think the pandemic really
interrupted like I think they're gonna
do a season two and Beyond so since that
show came out and they put it on YouTube
uh people have been asking Ahmed best
online hey are we ever going to see this
character and anything else again you
know is this character ever going to pop
up in like an animated thing or a video
game or comic books or whatever and he
was always like I haven't heard anything
I would love to play this character I
have I feel like I have more to sort of
explore with Keller and Beck because he
designed this whole sort of backstory
that you don't really get you don't get
to see it all in the kids game show
that's not the format for that kind of
story so when that door slid open and it
was Keller and Beck I was like number
one it's Ahmed best number two I am
familiar with this character how cool
that they're fully bringing him into
Canon because the the kids talk like
game show may or may not be Canon I
don't think it is it's not it's not
considered official Star Wars lore but
yeah man oh man what a moment I loved it
the way he says uh you're safe with me
kid you know it was so reassuring it
felt like he was rescuing Us in that
moment yeah you know even at this point
in the season of Mandalorian season
three there's a lot of like you know
people being toured in different
directions and when we look back at the
prequel era when we look back at the
sequel era it it just feels like there's
a lot of division in the Star Wars yeah
versus the Star Wars fandom right now
and this was one thing that I think is
just a universal Victory I think yes no
matter what your feelings are on Jar Jar
Binks you cannot have uh you cannot just
respect
um at best you have to understand he was
given a very difficult job and he
crushed it he crushed it he was he's
such a delight and he's always had such
a great attitude so the fact that they
gave this to him it's a meadow win it
fits canonically I think with with
everything there's no reason why he
couldn't be the guy on the other side of
those doors I'm so glad it was him I
felt rescued in that moment absolutely
and and you know there's a great term in
pro wrestling called The Forbidden door
which is like someone from another
Wrestling Federation or faction won't
wrestle like they don't like people in
aew don't wrestle in WWE or whatever I
feel like this was like the Forbidden
door of Star Wars like now any character
from a video game can show up in in a
Disney Plus show like now more than ever
I actually believe we might get live
action calcastes like just because of
yes I mean they pull they pulled the
character off of a game show and made
him amazing I mean you know I loved it I
could talk about it forever but we must
we must talk about these sick drips okay
have some great new Mandalorian inspired
items in their new the way collection
including a cute little founding shirt
Eric's got on uh and another shirt
called The Bounty Hunter with the
designs inspired by the best car steal
of Mandalore and if you purchase one of
these shirts you can opt to unlock a
shout out on this show like this one
from James Garman Angela this is the way
Angela that's my Tony Danza from who's
the boss or this one from Heather
Heather Steven Matt Kyle and Emma thank
you for watching with me love y'all so
visit
now thanks Heather Thanks James you guys
are the best we love you visit nerd
riot.shop now to grab one of these great
designs and don't take it off till the
finale next month don't worry about
stinking who cares who cares if you
smell a little funky you look good if
you smell funky act funky okay now Eric
Hector
my boys my sweet sweet boys who the [__]
is Keller and Beck we've gone into it a
bit yes
so we know who Ahmed best is and we know
that this was basically the Mark Summers
or Kirk fog of the Star Wars yes uh
franchise right uh host of the Jedi
Temple challenge kids game show that
came out in June 2020 just a nice little
uh Oasis there in the in the Velvet
crotch of covid but the
but man this guy has been with with us
since uh The Phantom Menace as the the
mocap performer and uh the voice of Jar
Jar Banks and and such a great such a
great personality and someone who has
had to weather all kinds of storms uh
because yeah I think we can all remember
how much he charge our banks received
yeah uh but they did bring him back an
attack of the Clones he played one of
the club goers in Coruscant uh his
character's name was Ahmed Beck uh and
in interviews Ahmed Vesta says that his
game show character Kellerman Beck is
related to Ahmed back so in a way he
already kind of threw interviews
established himself as Canon which is
the way you do it that is the way you do
it don't wait to get the call from
polony you just decide if you'll be like
yeah sure you're nice enough yeah I feel
like Dave seems like the type of person
that's like yeah that sounds good that
sounds about right and what's great
about this is as the host uh like he's
talked in interviews about how he wanted
to not just host that show as Ahmed best
he wanted to play it as a Jedi master
that was really important to him because
he knew kids were watching this and he
wanted the kids to be able to suspend
their disbelief and feel like they were
in the hands of a Jedi master and that
in a way absolutely affected uh
lucasfilm's decision to bring him back
here they wanted us to feel safe in the
hands of a master and not just kids uh
those of us a man man talk to us like
man come hit me like we grew up with
these with with this character and we
we've been with him on his journey this
way so to have him have this Victory it
means so much obviously to all of us uh
canonically though canonically though it
re it reckons his role as as the host of
this TV show as someone who is
responsible for looking after Jedi
younglins uh and padawans uh who are
lost in in the way now Eric uh not to
interrupt uh correct me if I'm wrong
they killed real children on that game
show right oh yeah looks like younglings
okay yeah yeah if you lose it's um yeah
there's the 500 first clone trooper of
Italian on the other side of that job
you know Disney Disney was really
excited about developing actual
lightsabers and that was the first
project they used them on and those kids
got a hold of them and those kids uh
took themselves out so you know yeah
yeah it's on them very sad they signed
the waivers but uh I think where they're
going next they they jumped out of uh
the Coruscant atmosphere into hyperspace
uh they were rescued that was the Senate
guard hard that's who that group was so
it's like the last group I know of
course not right now who might help them
uh those are the guys who like were
escorting uh bail or Ghana
um they don't have any kind of chips to
turn on Jedi no uh they aren't fully
yeah it's it's someone who might still
be loyal to the Jedi Order but those
guys uh not long but it sounds like
kelleran had this system set up in place
there's like a group of Jedi who knew to
get the child to to Keller in uh
kelleran has like a plan in place he's
got the earthquake kit ready to go yes
uh and he had this the system so the
fact that he had this like I think we
are seeing the origins of what was
called the path Obi-Wan Kenobi like
Hillary might have been the first person
to lay the Stepping Stones yeah of that
are we gonna see your uncle Quinlan Voss
you think I hoped it might have been
Quinlan Voss but I'm much I'm much Tommy
I have to I have to to correct you that
is Eric's great great great great great
great great great great great great
great great great
grandfather remember it's a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away yeah but we
call him Uncle quickly uncle uncle
Quinlan please yeah call me call me
Quinn this is such a great another great
example of the tragedy of Star Wars
which is all of the Jedi characters and
the children apparently die uh in order
66 because they're not around in
storytelling that takes place after and
now whether it's Ahsoka Tano or Keller
and Beck baby grogu or even that baby uh
that young Wookie Jedi that were
introduced that then we learn in the bad
batch actually survived there's all
these amazing characters that Dave
filoni and other people are helping to
create that all of them I think are too
heartbroken to actually give in to the
order 66 storyline they go no no they
also they also found it they also found
a way so then that's why I think they
created the path and all that great but
I want to ask both of you guys do you
think that kelleran survives Order 66
and like you're saying Eric goes on to
sort of help you know create this sort
of underground network of Jedi
younglings and other people that are
underground resistance or rebellion in
the early stages of of uh the Empire I
think so I mean we have to question like
how Keller and lost grogu at some point
right like how he fell into the hands of
that nikto gang in the Mandalorian pilot
um so but I mean that's like several
decades from now like there's he could
have lived a long happy life that we
need to see on Disney Plus in the
kelleran Chronicles never mind that
Disney's scaling back and canceling
other shows probably and firing people
this is one thing that you need to Green
Light yeah and expedite the production
right now uh but yeah yeah I think he
does he obviously survives getting away
from Coruscant I think at that point
that was the hardest part of it who
knows where he's gonna be hyperspace
jumping to at this point Hector I think
you're right did anyone die in order
success because they all just meet up at
a barbecue like two years later they're
like wait year
you're the hey you're alive us too oh my
God one two guys all of us are here oh
except for Kitty Mundi oh
look like a couple suckers and they
couldn't survive already 66. we got kids
surviving it's in some ways it's a lot
easier for others anyway not to mention
all the awesome characters that they
keep revealing in like novels and comic
books there's that great Jedi that that
is introduced in the Darth Vader series
that takes place right after the events
of Revenge of the Sith who was this Jedi
far off in the corner of the Galaxy that
was meditating the whole time and he was
like super badass so there anytime they
want to introduce a character that no no
they weren't anywhere near Order 66 and
they're a Jedi they can just do it and
it's been awesome so yeah Speaking of
awesome let's thank one of our generous
sponsors today if saving more and
spending less is one of your top goals
for 2023 why are you still paying insane
amounts of money every month for your
phone bill switching to Mint mobile is
the easiest way to save this year as the
first company to sell premium wireless
service online only mint mobile lets you
order from home and then save a ton with
phone plans starting at just 15 dollars
a month 15 clams 15 bucks 15 bones okay
listen
let's be honest 15 is a lot of money for
a man like me but for for Hector it's
nothing that's one of his premium lattes
he's always trying to pour on me in the
morning when I don't do the right thing
at work uh I I personally feel that this
is going to revolutionize cell phones
I'm bullish on mint guys for people
looking for extra savings this year mint
mobile offers premium Wireless like I
said for just 15 bucks not 16 bucks Eric
not 17 bucks not 18 bucks 15. gosh dang
ding dong Dixon bucks by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes
significant savings onto you I mean who
doesn't like that all plans come with
unlimited talking text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network baby the 5G they're tracking
us use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan you got a pink flip phone
they'll use that switch easily in
minutes with the e-sim I'm about to
e-sim right now switch to Mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at say it with me
15 simoleons to get your new Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com break room that's
beenmobile.com break room cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com break room use that break
room code and go to Turbo Tax and don't
do your taxes meet with an expert who
will do them for you Turbo Tax experts
can relieve you from the stress of taxes
and file for you so you can do not taxes
show your eyes things that are not taxes
unpack a moving box of not taxes taste
not taxes sing not tax is a lullaby hope
not taxes sleeps through the night grab
a saddle and ride not taxes into the
sunset with TurboTax an expert will do
your taxes from start to finish ensuring
your taxes are done right guaranteed so
you can relax feels good to be done when
your taxes doesn't it come to Turbo Tax
and don't do your taxes visit
turbotax.com to learn more Intuit
TurboTax full service products only
video meeting while expert does your
taxes required see guarantee details at
turbotax.com
guarantees boys let's get back into it
how many other Jedi do we think knew
about grogu now that we know that that
he was rescued by a Jedi yeah he it
seemed pretty siled off
um we know like my my theory for a long
time was that it was yattle but uh I
think Seattle definitely was around when
grogu was alive if Greg was 50 years old
then he's the same age as Anakin
Skywalker yaddle of course died at the
hands of Dooku in that episode of that
amazing episode of tales of the Jedi so
yato might have known I have to assume
that uh Yoda Master Yoda knew that that
yaddle ex or the adult and that grogu
existed
um but yeah it was like these other
these seem to be a group of Jedi Masters
these were not other students these were
this was like a a group a chain of
command right A specific group of
teachers that all were kind of his
handlers
um I think it's interesting that uh we
didn't talk about this before but um
kelleran got into what looked like a
Naboo Cruiser right it was the same kind
of design as what looked like it was
part of padme's uh her Naboo Starfighter
or her Cruiser so is that just a
reference to the fact that ahmedabes
played you know Senator Banks and that
it's just kind of like it's part of the
Naboo delegation I would imagine they're
not going to take him to Naboo because
that's like Palpatine that's kind of his
you know his publicly home planet but
here's the thing Eric here's the thing
what planet did Anakin Skywalker come
from and where did they hide Anakin
Skywalker's kid from like a very good
Star Wars Galaxy is small it's very very
small and that never fails to come up is
the that's the last place they'll look
it's right under their nose like I
immediately thought they're gonna take
him to Naboo I thought that Keller and
Beck had some kind of a system set up on
Naboo and knowing that that Palpatine
might have like an iron grip over it I
still feel like Naboo evokes the sense
of Padme Amidala the gungans all of
these people on Naboo we're fighting for
justice we're fighting for equality so
there is a sense of like there's kind of
a hope there and maybe maybe grogu could
have spent some years there and been
okay but honestly I don't know maybe
they're going to take Roku to Tatooine I
say take him to Buffalo get him some
wings at Duff's a hot dog at Ted's maybe
some mighty taco maybe some Barbed bill
they got good Reubens guys obviously
Ahsoka didn't know but remember Ahsoka
had parted ways with the Jedi Order at
that point so it makes sense that she
wouldn't know yeah um but it may have
just been something like after Ahsoka
left grogu was kind of unveiled to
certain other Jedi or something like
that yeah the the timeline of this is
all very very important
um but like yeah he was obviously a
secret but it's just interesting that
they had this student at this school who
was getting private classes in another
room you know some of the other students
are like why are all the other like why
can't I get office hours why does he get
a cool little floating egg did you like
how the floating egg was different yeah
and then in the Jedi Temple like he had
a different egg then I don't think that
was the same one that we see him in
later like they keep swapping out
different eggs no the one he has this
year has upgraded it's like a little
more like yeah he has got a new nice
shiny one now
I the one the one moment in the show
that really uh certainly triggered some
some core memories for me was Den Jaron
going full hockey dead and being like my
son will fight your son he'll fight him
he'll fight him right now uh do we think
grogu's force abilities will be
considered cheating as he continues his
training like d damn giant seems really
on board with amusing him he's like do
the thing you do yeah I was worried he
was gonna Force choke and then the other
man alone he's gonna be like which
I think that's a great question though
Tommy and I feel like if anybody were to
ever throw any sort of side eyes through
their visors to din jar and he could
just be like I'm sorry who was the
person that United our ancient history
who was it was it someone who Who had
who wielded the dark saber what's very
important to our culture somebody who
was both Mandalorian and Jedi somebody
who had force abilities but also
subscribed to the Creed whatever that is
so he could just point to his kid and be
like my kids like that and if you guys
don't like that then you don't like our
culture well entire Visa is gonna say we
hate Uncle witch we're glad he died so
we could get his lightsaber back on
we hate Uncle Rich
we hate you Uncle Jamie that's from Love
Actually I think the fact that he first
slept uh doing some Luke Skywalker moves
I think that's as far as he he'll be
able to go when he's worth choking
people or if he ever pulls a lightsaber
on on them I think they're gonna be like
whoa we don't have room on the hunt easy
buddy easy always Point your weapon
downrange bro it's so funny how vague
grogu's abilities are because he's 50
years old like you said Eric he's the
same age as Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader
at this time right Darth Vader died a
few years prior but like he's he's as
old as that character he's 50 but he's a
baby who can't speak and he babbles but
he's like intuitive and he can kind of
pick things up but he also can't
move the way another 50 year old I don't
know it's just it's it's purposely vague
and he's very very cute and I am so
shocked anytime din does allow his son
to do anything because I'm like Bro
you've been with this kid for maybe a
year maybe two years according to John
Farrow maybe two and a half how do you
know what he is or isn't capable of
other than he's been able to like calm
down a Rancor and he's jumped around
because Luke Skywalker helped him to
jump around is he all of a sudden in
this few years developmentally so much
further ahead than he was when you
picked him up in that little floating
bassinet the first time it's weird it's
funny it's adorable
I can't imagine grogu is going to be
able to pull that jumping trick off
anymore because the next time Ragnar or
whoever faces him off in a duel that
teenage kid's gonna be like this Baby's
gonna jump and when he does I'm gonna
pop him with the paintball right in
midair yeah it's a one-trick pony what
else is grogu gonna do
paint them paint that little green
bastard now I also thought it was very
sweet that when uh when uh bocatan and
the team got back didn't immediately
went over and picked grogu up I was like
I don't know why that really got to me
he was like he because he was he just
saw someone else's son in Peril and he
was like I gotta go get put my boy in my
hands my family speaking of foundlings
are they gonna try and train those three
Raptor babies can you train Raptor
babies to be mandalorians this is the
way Tommy have have faith my friend they
can be trained those sweet eight foot
tall monsters can be trained hey maybe
not as mandalorians but as their Steed
perhaps I think this is setting up where
we're going with the mythosar I think
we're gonna see some of the mandala
we're gonna see the vislo family writing
these things as their mounts and it's
they're gonna have some Raptors that
they can use kind of like the navi
flying they're they're like yeah for the
Stark family yeah it's I mean there's so
many Game of Thrones parallels here and
I think there's uh with House of the
dragon and Game of Thrones and the
targaryens in fact the myth the star was
thought to be extinct and is actually
still alive I think we're gonna see the
the family of Vizsla they're gonna be
okay with uh bocatan Crees right in the
mythosar because they're gonna have
these Raptors I also think you know guys
the book of Boba Fett just happened
Danny Trejo is just a phone call away
call his ass up bring him into the Mando
season three have him train these giant
beasts the way he trained the rancor and
so and and Boba Fett gets to ride a
Rancor and din jar and Boca tan Crees or
POS vizla or the armor or whatever other
characters we want because like you said
Eric uh bokeh 10 is probably gonna be
riding a mythosaur all these other
Mandos get to ride uh these crazy uh
giant uh weird looking babies and it's
gonna be sweet they're not gonna be
babies forever they're not like grogu
grows they grow up I think it's a baby
forever what's the Simpsons quote baby
alligators may seem cute but they grow
up uh speaking of Boca tan do you think
she's playing to like take over this
covert and uh and then grab and then
challenged in for the dark saber it felt
like that conversation with the armorer
was planting the seeds of a of a coup I
think she's gonna be challenged to uh to
uh or she's going to be pressured to
challenge dinjarin because din jar and
you mentioned that moment when he goes
over to pick up grogu in that moment
doesn't that kind of defeat what he's
trying to do to train the kid to toughen
him up as a fountain Lane to suddenly
coddle him again like that I think I
think Papa dengarn is always going to
feel those paternal instincts to protect
him and he's not going to he's going to
eventually challenge that cult or um
that cult mindset of like this is the
way the foundling kind of belongs to the
tribe Paz even had that moment where he
grabbed his son and pulled him over to
him I I think that's going to break
apart like the the nuclear family
instincts is is something that cult
ideology always feels as a threat you
have to break that down and call
People's parents suppressive persons and
so that really like David show us where
Shelley is where is your where's Shelly
I'm excited about Top Gun I'm excited
about Mission Impossible I just want to
know where Shelly is that's all I'm
gonna go see Mission Impossible okay but
just show me where Shelley is Tom Cruise
I'll watch you jump a motorcycle off
anything just tell us where Shelly is
you know but Eric you bring up a good
point because my take on this is is that
I think that Bo Katan was genuinely
moved by the love and the acceptance she
was shown by this crew the fact that she
had the honor of sitting next to the
fireplace that even though it's a cult
mentality and she's like how the hell
are we supposed to eat fair question Bo
fair question but didn't explain to her
yeah well normally part of the the
culture here is that you go off and you
find a place to eat privately and you do
your thing it's not that big a deal and
she was like okay cool I'm down but the
fact that that little scene showcased
pause Vizsla showing the honor of this
Mandalorian culture and saying you get
to be the one you're our leader you get
to be the one to sit by the fire I think
she's taking all of that in and my take
is is that because of Boca Tan's history
as someone who doesn't subscribe to this
very extremist version of the
Mandalorian culture and she takes her
helmet off Mando denjarin he took his
helmet off for his son because he loves
his son done so much he did it for that
moment that I think he's kind of the
bridge between both of those ways of
thinking like he was willing to take his
helmet off for something very important
to him and bocatan would do it all the
time and the extremist covert never
really does it the children of the watch
I believe that Beau having seen the
mythosaur is going to somehow prove that
maybe the mythosaur will return maybe
that's going to lead to something but I
think she's going to be able to unite
all of the Mandalorian people and change
their minds about some of their extreme
sort of beliefs and and core beliefs and
the other piece of evidence I have for
this is that in the past two seasons
um Paz of Isla was voiced by John
Favreau to go back to as a sort of a
throwback reference to how John Favreau
voiced a Vizsla character in The Clone
Wars but in this season it's not been
John Favreau it's been just credited as
Tate Fletcher the actor who is
physically embodying the the pause Visa
character I believe that's because at
some point in this season POS vizla is
going to take his helmet off and they
didn't want it to be favro they didn't
want you to kind of like be taken out of
that moment and they wanted to be an
actor and it's going to be the Tate
Fletcher performance actor because these
characters the armorer same thing I
believe that the this group this
Children of the watch may get to a point
where they change their minds and take
off their helmets but they're still
mandalorians Bo Katan will show them the
Way Boca tan will you'll not will unite
all the Mandalorian people because of
her connection to the mythosaur because
of this Mission and maybe through all of
that and maybe after defeating dinjarin
in combat and taking the darksaber back
and din's like cool I could just go and
be a dad on my own now with my son I
don't necessarily have to be a part of
this covert but instead can be you know
part of man of all of the mandalorians
as they all unite go back to Mandalore
and then there's your happy ending yeah
it works for me I hope Tate Fletcher
still has that wax mustache Under The
Helmet because that's that's only way
people are gonna recognize them but no I
yeah I think it's clear that din Jordan
does not want the dark saber he is
carrying it right now but every time he
unsheathes it he he can't handle it
um so I think that's his Destiny is I
think he's she's not gonna have to fight
him that hard for it
um so I think there's that I think the
fact that right now the armorer is
running things in this cult like a
proper Society needs to have you know
both a spiritual leader and someone who
is like the the leader leader uh so
right now the cult is being run by just
a high priestess you need someone who is
actually gonna like gonna be like the
physical leader the one leading the
charge so I think really this this cult
is in desperate need someone to step up
and for whatever reason Paz Visa hasn't
been that or at least we haven't really
seen that he's too busy as Tommy would
say laying down that pipe right just
having babies left and right come on
helmet on pants off that's the way we're
going off
get down
you just got peaceless you would think
out of all of the characters in Star
Wars that mandalorians would wear
protection but true did not this is the
way this is the way oh what a great
question do they have condoms in the
Star Wars Galaxy I want to know they
have to have they have to no they have a
little Droid down there it's just like
holds up a little umbrella he just wags
his finger at you
well we'll leave it there for this
episode of WikiLeaks again my Easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow you can
follow me today boss Holo Tommy Italian
and a huge thanks to Hector Navarro for
hanging out with us again this week a
lot of fun to chat about it with you too
uh we'll be back next week to react to
episode five of course the break room is
live every day at 3pm and you can check
out the Deep dive Please Subscribe uh
and yeah we have a new investigation
that digs into what the hell is going on
in Marvel Studios right now and we got a
deep dive of the 1989 Batman coming out
on Friday I think I really enjoy it you
can follow new rock stars please and
subscribe to WikiLeaks forever gear
podcast thank you for watching this is
the way
thank you